let's talk about the filming of what
went into this talkie sorry first of all
why do you do it uh why did we do it I
think I think we we enjoyed the idea
that it was going to be this this
document of our life there for who knows
how long like I thought I don't know why
did why did we do it well originally I
think of like a really good way to
explain what we did I I don't know
originally we I have experience in TV
both M design renovation and reality TV
and originally we had thought that it
would be cool since I host a design show
and we were thinking about doing our own
renovation why not ask the network if
they'd be interested in in following us
along and you know there's perks to that
that help you pay for the renovation so
we thought that would be really great
for us to do that or pregnant and we're
going to sell our old house and when I
got in this fun show and it's a journey
to but you know after a few days of
spending with the cameras the network
came back to us and they were like I
think we need to change the scope this
is more of a non reality show but a
docu-series like they just saw you know
one of the first days of filming you're
going to see on the episode tonight you
know I get this call while I'm on set
and I'm freaking out and I literally
thought I lost Justin like I thought
like it was just most terrifying thing
and the cameras were like what should we
do like this show is supposed to be
about them renovating a house but now
she's got this terrifying call let's
follow her so that all this footage that
was kind of unrelated to the house but
was awesome and so they asked us would
you be willing to open up your your
hearts and your life in your soul and I
at first wasn't comfortable with it but
Justin was like sure not really that
that surprises me I would have probably
thought it would be the other way around
you being so familiar with TV you not so
much
so what was it that made you want to
jump in I honestly I think it made the
crew we've known for that I've known for
last five years because they've been
filming gel it's the same crew from love
it elicits so for me it was like hanging
out with a bunch of good friends and we
had cameras and it was a lot of fun at
the start and it was
totally new from you is a completely new
endeavor and I thought it was a
fantastic opportunity and I thought why
not like its what else do you give you a
chance to try this absolutely and it is
like a moving photo album sort of your
lay old away and that's on one part like
Jess and I both love that adrenaline I
was like what's what's going to happen s
but the moving photo album the night
that I went into labor
there was miss supposed to be no cameras
coming with us at the emergency room and
the first person Justin called was the
camera crews because they just happened
to be in town for one more day in
Kelowna and I'm like no no no no no no
way and he was like first of all we
signed up for this and I was like no
still no yeah things like second of all
thinkable being able to have this
documented by professionals for the rest
of your life and so I was like Kate
everybody in the car like Caitlin was
their makeup artist and and the
producers and sound guys and my dad and
new cousins and Wow crazy